[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gérard larcher le président du sénat est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
soi et merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
cinq jours du second tour des
législatives alors bien sûr on nous
annonce un parlement macron vous
répondrais ce soir à jean francis
pécresse des échos et de radio classique
à nadège peljak de l' agence
france-presse et de michaël szames s de
public sénat trois grandes questions
vous seront posées ce soir gérard
larcher d'abord est ce la fin de
l'opposition ensuite est ce que vous
prenez une attitude constructive enfin
votre party les républicains est il un
parti en sursis mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
il ya bien sûr des voix à droite qui
appelle au sursaut gérard larcher mais
franchement c'est plié en tous les cas
dimanche
la france va donner au président de la
république une large majorité
c'est d'ailleurs une logique des
institutions n'a souvent dit que depuis
la réforme du quinquennat
c'était la réplique sismique de
l'élection présidentielle disons que sur
l'échelle de richter
c'est une réplique est forte oui mais la
démocratie c'est aussi à côté d'une
majorité stable et clair une opposition
responsable qui propose et une
opposition qui parfois doit aussi au
delà du contrôle s'opposer et qu'il doit
exister d'abord est ce que vous pensez
possible rééquilibrage des sédiments
je pense que ce rééquilibrage c'est ça
la notion du sursaut est nécessaire y
compris pour la réussite du cac et da
d'emmanuel macron comment ça parce que
je vais le dire je compare souvent ça à
la claude basque il faut un fronton
parfois pour renvoyer les balles et pour
construire dans le pays il faut toujours
que le débat ait lieu au parlement sinon
ça se termine dans la rue et c'était une
des inquiétudes que j'avais exprimé chez
un de vos confrères la semaine dernière
dans le parisien 1
mais alors je ne comprends pas quels
sont vos arguments alors pour essayer
d'obtenir ce rééquilibrage
alors qu'on entend sur le terrain des
candidats aient l'air
i qui défendent emmanuel macron près de
52 % de nos compatriotes
les électeurs n'ont pas voté et c'est
quand même un vrai sujet attention la
tentation du parti unique la première
victime
ce serait la participation citoyenne
comme si tout était réglé et je dois
dire que il est important que celles et
ceux qui sont attentifs au
fonctionnement de la démocratie ne se
disent pas c'est plié
c'est réglé il faut que dimanche ils
aillent voter quelle que soit leur vote
je crois que la première réponse et doit
être une réponse de citoyens alors vous
nous dites à l'une en fait un sursaut
politique mais également un sursaut
citoyen oui indispensable parce que vous
savez aujourd'hui près de 2 si on prend
le chiffre 23 % des français avait
choisi emmanuel macron va y avoir 80 %
de députées chez les chiffres qu'on
annonce oui ce qu'il n'y a pas une
petite discordances dans tout ça alors
vous connaissez bien sûr parfaitement la
carte électorale nationale gérard
larcher alors on va prendre l'exemple
des yvelines le département où vous êtes
et les résultats très médiocres
c'est incroyable et ignorait sans doute
il pourrait n'y avoir aucun député de
droite pour réunion en occaz que vous
avez jamais mon pire cauchemar imaginez
un tel dégoût même cauchemar
non je regarde la réalité en face voyant
des des candidats qui n'étaient inconnu
sur le terrain en fait ils sont des
hologrammes d' emmanuel macron c'est ça
qui a déterminé de l'élection c'est
aussi parce que notre pays a une telle
angoisse telle situation de désarroi le
désir qu'on travaille ensemble qui sont
allés vers ce ce choix et beaucoup de
nos candidats sont vraiment ces zones
europe des macros et je le dis avec
respect dont les candidats et pour
emmanuel macron oui mais vous vous dites
quand même à propos des manoeuvres macro
produite quand même chapeau l'artiste
parce qu'alors franchement y aller en un
peu plus de 12 mois regarder ce qu'il a
réalisé un nom un sans faute
il réussit parfaitement ses traditions
le désagrément des pays
dans un quinquennat qui avait été
l'échec absolu un président de la
république qui a réussi à tuer quasiment
totalement son parti politique d'achat
pour le reste je dis chapeau politique
chapelles politiques
il faut se souvenir qu'il ya six mois en
annoncé 400 450 députés de droite année
c'est en tous les cas ce que vous me
posiez comme question à la fin de
l'année voilà on voit bien qu'en
démocratie rien n'est jamais acquis
avant le choix des électeurs alors la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité tout de
suite avec michaël szames s2 public
sénat qui vient vous poser sa question
[Musique]
concerne michael bon sens michel vorm
sur l'arche et conçoit donc l'ami
compris avec eux ce que vous venez dire
avec avec michel conscient avec la vague
qui se prépare à déferler sur
l'assemblée nationale vous diriez qu'il
n'y a plus d'opposition
d'abord je souhaite dire aux français
qui nous écoutent qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une opposition
c'est indispensable pour la démocratie
la démocratie c'est comme un coeur des
deux ventricules ou deux piliers des
piliers docteur kiffer c'est le rôle de
la majorité qui conduit une politique
qui soutient un gouvernement et un autre
pilier qui s'assure qu'ils proposent qui
peut d'ailleurs co construire à certains
moments mais qui est la garantie de
l'expression de doutes d'interrogations
et qui est une exigence signe presque
plus ou plus d'opposition vous avez dit
de ne parler du risque de la rue est ce
qu'il ya un risque pour la démocratie
comme le dit notamment cas le patron du
parti communiste le risque de la rue
c'est naturellement le risque pour la
démocratie
je préfère que ce soit au parlement ce
débat voilà pourquoi à l'assemblée
nationale il est important chaque député
d'opposition en plus par rapport aux
projections
ce sera un peu plus de démocratie
vivante c'est un point important
président la république sûr d'avoir
cette majorité claire et stable
en plus il se dit que les nouveaux
députés marcherait en fils
c'est à dire c'est à dire trois reprises
ont négocié une lettre dit
pour aborder mais aucun mandat des
impératifs et vous savez j'ose espérer
que l'esprit de liberté dans portera
surtout ici au sénat on sait bien vous
avez l'esprit dîner l'assemblée
nationale et je crois vraiment qu'il ya
une responsabilité des citoyens et
chaque député d'opposition qui peut être
en même temps un homme positif
une femme positive c'est un peu plus de
démocratie les godillots va parler déjà
à l'époque de la droite il y aurait rien
de nouveau dans cela que rien de nouveau
on l'a connu en 1993
ce n'est pas terriblement bien terne à
l'époque où vous ne seriez pas inquiété
d'une sorte d'hégémonie ou d'absolutisme
politique quand c'était la droite qui
ont bénéficié que ça ton ania
je vous rappelle nous étions dans le
septennat et aujourd'hui on est dans la
réplique sismique de l'élection
présidentielle c'est d'ailleurs un un
vrai sujet par rapport à la réforme du
quinquennat
moi qui suis pour le scrutin majoritaire
en même temps je sais que nous aurons un
débat sur une place de proportionnelle
vous en pensez quoi de nous vivons au
sénat la proportionnelle puisque presque
deux tiers des sénateurs presque 75% de
mains des sénateurs seront élus à la
proportionnelle
je reste très attaché au scrutin
majoritaire qu'est la relation entre un
homme une femme et un territoire dont le
citoyen j'arrive ce territoire on
courait le débat sur une part de
proportionnelle n'est pas des gabelles
j'adore parce qu'il doit philippe ne
sait pas mesurer encore la hauteur
inhabituelle du bas ce sera entre 10 et
20% ne faut pas non plus que ce soit un
facteur d'instabilité de la réforme du
quinquennat est en train de démontrer ce
que nous répétions à quelques-uns
attention la république d'alors quel
rôle pour le sénat après que peut-être
on verra bien dimanche ont fait au moins
400 d
td de la république en marche et oui il
ya près de trois ans expérimentée j'ai
présenté ma candidature ici j'avais un
thème d'opposition constructive
lorsqu'à un mot qu'on répète beaucoup à
l'époque il était moins usité c'était un
choix que j'avais fait par rapport à
d'autres parce que je pense que le pays
attend de notre part
même si nous avons des idées différent
on se préoccupe d'abord de lui et quand
je disais toujours le pays c'est
beaucoup plus important que mon parti
moi qui me suis engagé extrêmement tôt
dans ma formation politique qui en suit
membres et donc je vis ça profondément
je dois dire et le sénat demain ça va
être un espace de vraie liberté à
l'endroit que l'assemblée y avoir de
l'exigence des propositions où on n'est
pas dans le dogmatisme et je dois dire
que dire c'est ce que voulait dire ici
je me demande tout à fait pour ça le
salaire de l'assemblée est-ce que
l'assemblée parce que c'est pas un mot
facile godillots peut-être eux
moi je fais confiance aux collègues de
l'assemblée nationale
ça fait mais ici il ya un espace de
liberté il ya un espace d'initiative
c'est vrai que nous ne sommes jamais
aligné nous ne sommes jamais en fils
souvenez-vous du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy la majorité ici était
majoritairement dans la majorité
présidentielle de l'époque et pourtant
sur nombre de sujets là exprimé sa
liberté que vous entendez que le sénat
exprime encore plus sa singularité la
majorité sénatoriale n'est pas
automatiquement calquée sur la majorité
présidentielle c'est un point important
de même que l'opposition au sénat
s'appelle souvent groupes minoritaires
plutôt groupe d'opposition et moi je
suis très attentif aux droits de
l'opposition
cela va d'ailleurs à ce sujet à
l'assemblée nationale puisque nous
aurons des groupes d'opposition à gauche
comme au centre et à droite qui seront
on le sait beaucoup plus réduit qu'on ne
l'imaginait
droits de l'opposition c'est quelque
chose d'essentiel que vous avez mesuré
l'impact de la république en marche sur
les futures élections sénatoriales
non mais ça peut avoir un impact
le vrai sujet c'est que notre corps
électoral en dehors d'avoir été
essentiellement constitué lors des
élections municipales puis les élections
départementales et régionales est
particulièrement attentif au sujet du
territoire jusque là on n'a pas beaucoup
entendu lille président de la république
il premier ministre sur le sujet du
territoire le rôle et la place de la
commune des intercommunalités dans le
cadre d'un one hot la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation les réformes des dotations
quelle vision de la poursuite ou non de
la décentralisation des premiers signaux
qu'on a reçues sont plutôt des signaux
de recentralisation ça faisait donc
c'est des vrais gignacois trois semaines
un mois oui ça va barder au président de
la république je disais au président de
la république en le recevant il a eu la
courtoisie de venir me voir
la veille de son investiture et nous
avons eu un échange nous étions tous les
deux et dans cet échange j'ai dit
monsieur le président vous êtes le
président d'un pays fracturée et
d'appeller fracturé en plus
géographiquement et territorialement et
que le rôle du sénat
c'est d'essayer de contribuer à recoudre
ce territoire il n'y a pas qu'une france
de métropole et de quelques régions
puissante
il ya une france qui est tout à la fois
et je crois que une partie des votes
extrêmes
c'est le sentiment presque d'une
majorité de nos concitoyens de ne plus
être dans le jeu aujourd'hui de ne plus
être considéré de pu être pris en cours
est ce qu'on peut vous demander quelle a
été sa réponse qu'il y serait très
attentif et que nous c'est un débat que
nous allons poursuivre donc vous la
norme wahlberg liste nationale rochelle
et nous nous rencontrerons très bientôt
avec le président de la république
vous savez moi c'est ma manière vous
faire merci beaucoup michael mai 2008
c'est jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir jean françois michel bonsoir au
soir larcher alors il y a des bâches et
les républicains sur la nature de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron et à
cette majorité cette majorité massive de
la république en marche débat entre nos
positions constructives et une position
plus obstructive est ce que vous serez
en tant que président du sénat partisan
d'une opposition constructive d'une
position je crois que je me suis déjà on
va l'expliquer en répondant aux
questions de votre confrère c'est depuis
trois ans la tique et que nous avons je
rappelle quand même que nous avons voté
près de 75% des textes après amendement
des gouvernements de manuel valls et
jean que c'est ici l'adn de la maison
est-ce qu'on est constructive pour être
constructif non ce qui compte c'est et
c'est d'ailleurs la tombe de nos
concitoyens en sorte notre pays des
grandes difficultés qu'il connaît en
matière d'emploi
en matière de dépenses publiques en
matière de déficit
c'est sale attente de nos concitoyens
alors est ce que mon attitude et
constructive obstructive sur armand
obstructif sauf quand on touche aux
libertés fondamentales
c'est un point sur lequel on ne transige
pas souvenez vous de la réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par françois
hollande de la déchéance de nationalité
et de mes propos sur ce plateau sur le
passeport dans scène sur l'apatridie
quand on dit non ici on dit rarement
espèces état non absolu est ce que ça
veut dire que vous vous opposeriez à
l'intégration des dispositifs des
dispositions de l'état d'urgence dans la
loi ordinaire
d'abord nous allons débattre au mois de
juillet de la reconduction jusqu'à
l'automne et de l'état d'urgence dans le
cadre mais il y à un débat qui n'est pas
médiocre qui a déjà été ici entamé
largement par le président de la
commission des lois
philippe bas et par michel mercier donc
le rapporteur et sur les sujets par
exemple
du de la rétention administrative sur le
suivait le sujet du suivi de
personnalité entre guillemets
personnalité plutôt de personnes fichées
ou particulièrement suivie il ya un
sujet sur par exemple les perquisitions
tous ces sujets là on sera attentif aux
libertés glee gels ans on sera vigilant
parce que la limite ici c'est la
protection des libertés individuelles et
collectives
mais en même temps on ne méconnaît pas
la réalité du terrorisme bien ceux de
l'insécurité mais il ya encore une fuite
peut-être dans la presse je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez mais là on avoue
également la semaine dernière dans le
monde un avant texte inquiets par
exemple donnait le pouvoir à la justice
administrative
est-ce que ce tas ça vous inquiète t
elle à ce que vous pourriez faire
blocage c'est sans doute sur ces sujets
là que nous serons particulièrement
attentifs
c'est un poids sur lesquels nous étions
déjà attentif y est bien longtemps et je
pense que cette maison qui a mis en
place je le rappelle la commission
informatique et libertés le mot liberté
est un mot qui est très haut sur le
fronton du sénat mais concrètement alors
ouais enfin où hélas la ligne à ne pas
franchir
elle est où cette ligne entre cette
ligne à ne pas franchir
est-ce que c'est dispositions de l'état
d'urgence actuelle elle ne vous choque
pas non mais je rappelle que c'est une
disposition exceptionnelle pour un temps
de délicieux où le contrôle sous le
contrôle des juges deux commissions de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
si un certain nombre de procédures
deviennent des procédures ordinaires
il faut s'assurer que les libertés
individuelles et collectives soit
assurée alors vaut mieux parler sans
doute un français de la loi travail pour
la méthode d'abord est ce que la méthode
des ordonnances vous êtes
ben oui jésus avait même préparé pour
nos candidats août à travers alors me
pose aucun problème problème alors je le
dis comme président
du sénat les ordonnances oui la
commission mon poids en abuser
ordonnance oui mais le débat doit aller
dans le cadre d'une ordonnance au fond
que ce soit un moment de l'habilitation
qu'au moment de la ratification le débat
il doit aussi qu'un débat en commission
qui permet d'entendre sur le sujet
travail-emploi l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux
ça n'est pas un espèce de débat cash et
subreptice conclu on prêtait qu'il
faudrait aller vite
c'est ce que disent les syndicats tien
passé j'étais encore aujourd'hui oui
enfin de pseudo dialogue social en tous
les cas moi personnellement j'avais
entamé avec eux au mois de décembre
ce dialogue sur des sujets qu'on doit
retrouver dans les ordonnances que le
sujet du rôle de la place et du niveau
de l'accord d'entreprise et de branches
en tous les cas vous avez rencontré la
ministre du travail à ces quelques jours
vous l'avez dit vous êtes sur la même
longueur d'onde quoi pas sur tous les
sujets le globe and évidemment mais je
connais bien le ministre du travail
puisque quand j'ai terminé du travail je
lui avais proposé elle était devenue
d'être président de l'institut du
travail
il dira que je pensais que c'était une
femme qui connaissait bien ses sujets là
il ya d'autres sujets dans les
ordonnances qui sont des sujets
particulièrement importants
la question de la sécurisation de l'
embauche et notamment la question des
indemnités devant les prud'hommes
c'est un élément de sécurisation moi
j'aurais souhaité qu'on y met aussi les
seuils jeudi à la ministre
car les seuils passé de 10 à 20 les
seuils sociaux 1 c'est-à-dire les les
seuils ray de dons ou d'envoi ou à
l'adsl sa créance à sas a créé de
l'emploi d'accord et notre sujet
aujourd'hui vous avez que ça me sourit
chiffres sur un peu mais des 30
entraîneurs sur vous avez le sentiment
d'être entendu écouté parce que ce sera
le rôle du débat parlementaire
ouais d'accord on va parler de la
moralisation de la vie publique dont le
projet la confiance donc de la confiance
dans la vie et dans le dos les projets
de loi ou le projet de loi arrive en
conseil demain mais avant je voulais
savoir il ya débat encore il ya un autre
débat
pour ce moment au sein des républicains
sur le sud sur la question de savoir si
il faut voter la confiance au premier
ministre edouard philippe ou pas d'abord
je voulais savoir si l'eau si le
gouvernement demande au sénat un vote de
confiance est ce que vous êtes enclin à
la voter cette science aujourd'hui
d'abord et salue pas une obligation du
salary sonia la différence sur ça que
vous dit de l'assemblée nationale
c'est un des sujets dont nous parlerons
avec le premier ministre la semaine
prochaine s'il souhaite ou non demander
la confiance aussi au sénat vous savez
pour voter la confiance vous connaître
le texte vous connaître sur quoi la
confiance est appelée de quelle manière
elle est appelée la confiance c'est pas
non plus une espèce de prison derrière
laquelle on s'enferme c'est pas un
blanc-seing qui est donné
donc il y aura débat à l'intérieur des
groupes et c'est à l'issue du débat à
l'intérieur des groupes que sera décidé
ou non de voter cette confiance on ne
regarde jamais les choses a priori ici
au sénat
donc elle n'est pas automatique m elle
ne va pas de soi le vote de confiance de
la part naturelle ne va pas de soi la
confiance et je crois que la confiance
elle se construit elle se construit par
les propositions et il appartiendra au
premier ministre de faire des
propositions
il viendra devant le sénat pour nous
faire part de ses propositions un de vos
amis de 5 juillet prochain c'est au
moins la date que nous avons près
retenue et donc nous écouterons et nous
verrons si nous partageons pas leur
certains vos amis ont une position
anticipé parce qu'ils nous annoncent
déjà qu'ils voteraient la confiance
votre écoute merci beaucoup merci mme
jean francis dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
nadège peljak de l' agence france presse
qui nous rejoint pour parler politique
heller
l'épreuve de vérité avec life et
françois richer vont soit registre non
alors tout simplement si je vous
demandais mots pour qualifier l'état de
votre parti en ce moment vous dites quoi
ah bon hamon médicale oh comme vous
voulez il sera en crise il en crise bien
sûr mais il ne nous lie ficultés qu'un
homme ou une femme d'esprit ne puisse se
transformer en succès en sursis tant sur
sa part dit non je pense que nous avons
un travail d' analyses pour établir les
diagnostics pourquoi nous en sommes là
pourquoi nous avons échoué
tout au long de ces années et notamment
de cette dernière n'est que nous avons
les mains surtout de cette dernière
année parce que les autres années ça
c'était pas si mal passé que ça après
tout il est bien morte et les
législatives partielles vous avez un
grand combat les mégots du bruit venait
vous n'étiez pas de batterie et puis là
l'avons connu une crise de gouvernance
nous avons connu des questions des
interrogations sur le financement de
campagnes politiques
et puis cet amant présidentielle sur le
fonctionnement du parti
tous ces sujets là nous les avons
traités mais en même temps elles ont
suscité des interrogations légitimes
chez nos concitoyens
je crois que nous devons aussi leur
poser la question depuis 2002 nous
étions rassemblés les radicaux des
républicains indépendants des gaullistes
et chrétiens démocrates
qu'est-ce qui est notre lien aujourd'hui
pour être enceintes si vous allez vision
de la société
quelle solidarité qu'a l'illusion de la
communauté nationale
quelle place de la france comment nous
voyons l'europe
non mais les urgences mais oui mais
c'est ça ce qui forge le coeur d'un
mouvement politique
alors françois baroin a dit on
s'occupera du parti après les
législatives alors aisance
il est bien sûr qui a bien sûr c'est pas
à moi de le dire vous c'est vous qui le
dites mais ce que je veux dire c'est et
ça va tourner au pugilat ça tourne au
règlement de comptes
je ferai tout pour qu'il y ait un vrai
débat et que le vrai débat se limite pas
un combat de boxe parce que hier on
avait l'impression qu'il est un petit
peu un combat de boxe entre bureau
politique vous étiez en murs en planches
n'était pas là alors d'après ce qu'on
nous a dit j'ai quand même plusieurs
sources assez sûr qu'ils nous ont quand
même expliquer et que ça va barder si
j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
pour monsieur raffarin qui s'est même
levé près à partir finalement il s'est
rassis tout le monde s'est calmé
enfin alors en gros un j'explique en
vitesse cette situation monsieur
raffarin 10ème année trois qui sont au
gouvernement les trois ching qui son
gouvernement
voilà ils ont pas ils ont pas la gale
depuis qu'ils sont partis ils sont
toujours des nôtres
et puis toute façon il faut passer des
désaccords enfin et dans tous les cas il
faut dire qu on est d'accord avec
monsieur macron ils ont qui ont dit
écoute là vraiment en gros tu joues tu
roules tu joues contre ton quand elle
reste que c'est aussi votre sentiment
écoutez on était au lendemain d'un choc
terrible pour 452 nos candidats parce
que ce choc c'est le résultat du premier
tour nous avions beaucoup de candidats
nouveaux jeunes et qui espérait pouvoir
être élu et rencontrer la confiance des
français
je crois que ce débat il va venir il va
venir en son temps quand la avant les
vacances soient prêts à l'entendre
répondre un jour où un débat à paris la
semaine prochaine
aujourd'hui seul objectif celui du
sursaut que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
celui de notre mobilisation qui dépasse
même la terre est partisan c'est
l'intérêt de la démocratie parlementaire
l'avidité des forces et c'est vrai aussi
pour la gauche qu'il y ait des forces
d'opposition
est-ce que vous permettre à la
démocratie allait même si les deux
genres sénégal même si les deux genres
sont illégales et bien de trouver des
équilibres et nathalie kosciusko morizet
justement qui
est en ballottage très difficile hier
monsieur raffarin est allé l'aider sur
le terrain vous allez vous aussi vous
souhaitez quand il allait soutenir un
acte iv kosciusko morizet lors je vais
faire d'autres puisque on essaye de se
répartir bien sûr sur le terrain j'ai
soutenu si vous aviez lu un de vos
confrères aussi bien de te dis que cisco
morizet que d'autres et y compris les
thierry solère mais j'ai été dans
l'aisne me battre contre le front
national mais malheureusement du côté
des garçons avec un succès pas encore
totale parce que pour moi c'était la
priorité dans un département qui avait
donné la majorité à marine le pen et
qu'il soutiendrait vous pour prendre
parti diriger c'était la mairie il peut
toujours muter sujet on le parti sera le
moment venu un congrès aura le moment de
l'élection encore notables autour de
quel projet comme mondiale est devenue
notre vivre ensemble
est ce que le parti va sonner ou pas
tout à l'heure vous parlions écouter sa
musique indépendants vous savez que
c'est un nom qui circule pour une
nouvelle pas pour un nouveau parti droit
c'est étonnant qu'ils existent et au cdh
à un essai c'est plus plausible
s'attirer autant que ça a été juste
avant 2002 moi personnellement je ferai
tout pour un débat de qualité un débat
profondeur qu'ils soient pas combat de
boxe et pour reconstruire un parti parce
que je crois que nous avons une
responsabilité
l'implosion ça veut dire l'atomisation
l'atomisation ça veut dire la faiblesse
et on a deux voire d'être une opposition
qui exerce sa mission d'opposants pour
notre formation politique au parlement y
compris ici au sénat dans un groupe
comme le groupe des républicains
nous avons aussi un devoir de contrôler
le gouvernement de faire des
propositions de s'opposer quand nous
considérons qu'il est important utile
pour le pays de s'opposer
nous sommes là aussi pour contribuer à
redresser la fera encore une question au
président du sénat puisque nous sommes à
la veille de la comparution
ça devant le tribunal correctionnel de
paris du pneumologue michel aubier pour
témoignages mensongers sous serment
puisqu'il avait nié ses liens avec
certains industriels le groupe total
notamment et en minimisant par ailleurs
l'impact de la pollution est ce que vous
attendez de ce procès qu'on respecte
parlement et notamment quand on prête
serment devant une commission denquête
du parlement considérer que c'est une
chose sérieuse
à un moment on veut redonner confiance
en la vie publique
on veut redonner confiance dans la vie
politique le parlement est un élément de
la vie démocratique
le respecter et essentiel laissons faire
la justice
c'est vrai que nous nous sommes portés
parties civiles
c'est vrai que je serai représenté à
l'audience par le président de la
commission denquête de l'époque
jean-françois husson est naturellement
par un avocat qui défendra les intérêts
en que ça mérite vraiment condamnation
on n'intervenait pas dans les affaires
de justice
je vous laisse ce mot justice décidera
nous avons voulu le bureau à l'unanimité
toutes sensibilités politiques rappelé
que le parlement est une chose sérieuse
témoigner devant une commission denquête
du parlement est une chose très sérieuse
et le tribunal tranchera
devra le rappeler je comprends je
traduis un peu vos propos merci monsieur
larcher merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité
merci à tous bon soir à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]